the Trump administration waging a war
against jurisdictions that provide
sanctuary to illegal immigrants now
they've released some statistics to
support that concern more than 100
suspected members of ms-13 and other
gangs were released in sanctuary cities
and areas generally last year and that
came despite requests from the federal
government that they be held this is a
breakdown by state two-thirds of those
releases occurred in California
President Trump said on Twitter today
California's dangerous policies of
releasing violent criminals puts all
Americans at risk he also thanked San
Diego County for backing the
administration's lawsuit against the
state Kimberly what do you make of it my
California Californian I know we seem to
always go back and forth here on this
yeah it's really gotten to be pretty
accelerated an out of control in
California you know I remember the good
old days when I was back there and when
I was first lady in San Francisco seems
it's like it was just much more sane at
the time but now you have such a big
aggressive push you have backlash from
certain counties they're saying wait a
second don't lump us all into this we
want to follow the law we want to hold
the law we want fairness and we're
actually seeking justice not injustice
we want people to come into this country
legally we welcome with open arms
okay and that's that's how it should be
when you see the the law broken and
people coming in and essentially back
and forth revolving doors that's not
helping the immigrant illegal it's
coming in their families the children
the people get separated it's not
helping the local law enforcement and
ordinances and the border it's just
fraught with complications and problems
and this is an issue that President
Trump is not gonna give up on but it
also seems that you know Governor Brown
is digging in lieutenant governor Newsom
digging in and this is really becoming a
very large political issue for the
upcoming gubernatorial election okay so
Jesse help me out here just for a second
so the audience understands what's at
stake the sanctuary cities legislation
says basically if you have your average
illegal immigrant in jail they get out
of jail this the city of the state has
no obligation to notify the feds but if
it
a violent criminal they will let you
know and then of course if there's a
detainer or a warrant they definitely
are obligated to late it's a if it's a
felony beat that they're holding them on
it gives the locals discretion to
contact the feds doesn't mandate it but
there's also other elements so if you
pull over a guy for running a red light
he's got tattoos all over his face no ID
can't speak English you can't even ask
him about a citizenship and they
restrict ice access to prisons and you
can't hold an illegal immigrant longer
than you would otherwise while you wait
for the feds to slap what is what does
the president want so the president
wants the sanctuary cities defunded and
he wants a way that they would even with
someone who wasn't criminal or a violent
criminal that they would hold them and
tell the feds come get her I think they
prioritize it if it's someone that's not
here in this country illegally and it's
just like a small thing
maybe shoplifting or something tiny
obviously the feds are going to
prioritize it because they're busy but
if someone punches you in the face
steals a car is selling narcotics
something big then the president wants I
used to be able to there and go in there
and get those guys and then ship them
out so Kennedy what the numbers show
coming from the president the White
House today is we have 37 jurisdictions
that have been engaging in this kind of
behavior
obviously California 2/3 of these
numbers but you know states like
Washington Washington State also
involved all over the country what do
you think if that's how the states want
to play it that's fine and and if they
want to operate independently I don't
have a problem with that I also think
you know I happen to have a very high
opinion of most immigrants who come to
this country because most of them don't
commit crimes and they work very hard
and I hate to see them lumped in with
members of ms-13 the problem is if
you're letting bad people go and enter
into society and hurt people they get
really good at not getting arrested and
committing and continuing to commit
crimes and that's not OK and you end up
having a disingenuous conversation about
immigration and about crime and
unfortunately immigrants get tarred as
all being really bad people who want to
hurt you and take your stuff and by
that is just vastly not the case and I
also don't like that I I love California
like Kimberly I love it it's a great
state and I hate to see it torn apart I
hate to see the state turned into you
here they're on our team or you're not
you're us or them your force are against
us and that means that we have bad
immigration policy from the top that is
too confusing for states and counties
very it's very polarizing you make a
great point in the end the problem is is
that you see this injustice there's so
many hard-working men and women and
children to grow up then in this country
from fantastic immigrant backgrounds
like my families and contribute to
society we want to do it the right way
so it's unfair when we have to
stigmatize it but this is just the
lawlessness cannot be ignored when you
see people like ms-13 who I had a
prosecute you know when I was a DA in
San Francisco in Los Angeles I mean the
horrific crimes that are committed they
should not be allowed to come in and
re-enter again public safety issue Tyrus
I don't think he was talking about you
with the tattoos tattoos but you know I
was born in Massachusetts so I'm good
but I grew up in in California and I
don't see the upside of the argument
like I wish I look at things down the
middle and if you if you're here
illegally you're already breaking the
law and if you do something violent you
shouldn't be held up you should be held
up if you rob you still you do think if
it was a normal American citizen and he
had a warrant in a different place
they're gonna hold it right I think it's
only fair and you're the worst thing is
is they're encouraging the gang they're
encouraging gang members if you bring
more guys over because the worst thing
will happen is you'll do something and
then they'll let you're going no
California they know the laws you don't
matter then the people who are arresting
them best believe that these aren't this
isn't dumb these aren't dumb don't ever
think that these gangs are dumb they're
not they know the system better than the
system so they'll just keep coming as
long as there's not a deterrent there's
a turret they'll stop I think what you
said is true I just worry that we are
demonizing people who are hard it's not
fair it's not fair be good for someone
who came in the right way yeah yeah okay